Aww yeah! Let's learn English with Lady Gaga and
Ariana Grande's hit new song
Rain On Me
So I'm Andrea and I'm here to let you know that every
week we make lessons just like this one
to help you understand fast English
without getting lost,  without missing
the jokes and without subtitles.
Just like Aram, who says that he is addicted to our channel because it is the best way
to learn English on the internet.
So don't forget to hit that subscribe button and the bell down below so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Are you still finding it difficult to understand fast speaking natives?
Then I highly recommend our Fluent with Friends course.
In this 48 week course you will learn with the first two seasons of Friends.
Each week you will receive PDF power lessons, vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle
global community and so much more.
And the best part is you can try it right now for free
with our free three part Masterclass.
All you have to do is click up here or in the description box below to learn more and sign up now.
We hope to see you there.
Do you want to learn more English with Lady Gaga?
Then why not check out our lesson with her and Bradley Cooper singing the beautiful song "Shallow"
from A Star Is Born.
You can click up here or in the description box below to watch it straight after this lesson.